[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to San
Luis I'm Anastasia and I'm joined here
by Grandmaster Yasser ceravan so happy
to be with you yes what's the reaction
for the playoffs exactly hello everyone
and Welcome to our show it is indeed
playoff Thursday today we will Crown a
ladies Champion but who will it be let's
take a look at our two Gladiators we
have raveena crush and Jennifer you
there fighting for the first place right
now yeah in the competition itself they
have tied for first they got here in
different ways by the way Arena was
undefeated Jennifer lost a few games but
they tied her first and they're going to
have a drawing of lots that is coming up
really soon in fact let's go to
Christian in the playing hall for the
drawing of lots with Chris bird Chief
arbiter
thanks guys we are here in uh the
playing Hall as we are getting ready for
the playoffs to begin we will be doing
the drawing of the Lots with Chief
Arbiter Chris bird who is right now
doing the security tracks on a-time
National Champion Irina crush and the
way this is going to work is uh Chris is
going to pick up one white pawn and one
black pawn and then I believe is going
to be Irina who will be choosing uh the
hand and then we will know who will have
which color in the first game so Chris
are you ready to do that I'm certainly
ready so I have a wine and a black pond
I'm gonna randomize these and Irina if
you would be able to
choose either my left or my right hand
this one you will have this color in the
first game you will start with the black
pieces Jennifer will have the white
piece in the first game Jennifer you
with the white pieces in the first game
guys don't go anywhere playoffs is about
to start
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
two leading ladies remain standing at
the U.S Women's Championship in St Louis
Jennifer you simply refused to give up
slashing back after a loss to defeat of
surging Talia Cervantes for a chance to
end eight-time champ by Rina crush's
record-breaking title host you'd be
crazy to run from such a killer match-up
the final day of Championship chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the playoff
day here at the US Women's Chess
Championship we already know who the
Victor is in the open section that is
Fabiano caruana but which one of these
two ladies will take home the title will
it be the experienced Irina crush or the
youthful Journey for you let's go to the
studio and find out with Yasser and
Anastasia from the home of Chess in the
United States welcome to the Saint Louis
chess club and the playoffs of the US
Women's chess championships
hello everyone once again welcome back
uh now we know that Arena will have
black in the first round let's talk
about the format uh Anastasia what is
the playoff format
so we have two players left in the
championship both of them applied for
the first place what does it mean it
means they will play two rapid games
today with 10 minutes for Game Time
control plus two seconds uh increment
starting from one and in case if we
still have one one result in this case
we are going to have an Armageddon game
uh what does it mean it means we have
five minutes for why it's four for black
and in case if black wins this game
um or end it in a draw it means black
wins the the tournament and the women's
standings after 13 Rounds Ended as
follows we still have the playoff of
course yeah so because Arena and
Jennifer died for the first place we
still don't have a winner but we'll know
the name today right Silas Cervantes is
on the third position again I just have
to mention talia's result in the last
six games she she was on a five-game win
streak before she lost her last round
game against Jennifer which is why
Jennifer is in the finals and we have
also Ryan on the first place and in the
open who were the big prize money
winners there adiano caruana is the new
US champion he won this tournament for
the second time already and Ray Robson
boy he pushed him all the way to the
Limit there for a second yes and here
you also won 45 Southern great price and
we also have a tie for the third place
linear Dominguez and the Wonderland both
of them died for the third position and
they get thirty thousand very handsome
prizes indeed and Christian good to see
you back in studio here uh
drill down on these players tell us what
we can expect Christian I uh did do some
cardio running playing hole together
here in time but finally it is a
championship day here at the St Louis
chess club we have an amazing playoff
coming your way and let's take a look at
how the two players channel for you and
Irina Crush got to where they are today
because they had a definitely very
different results in this Championship
as you can see eight victories for Jenny
for you two draws and three losses on
the other hand Irina Crush has been
undefeated in this tournament zero
losses five wins and eight drops this
playoff is going to be a very
interesting battle between two very
different styles of uh players as well
and let's take a look at Jennifer you
and how she got here but also who is
Jennifer Ewell she is a young lady she's
only 20 years of age she is already a US
women's champion in 2019 she won that
with a dominant score 10 out of 11 she's
also a student at Harvard and she was
mentioning during the post game
interviews that she had a lot of
homework during this U.S chess
championships but what about her rival
Irina crushed while she is the only
Grandmaster in this event a Time
national championships 38 years young
and she's also one of only 39 women to
be awarded the Grand Master title guys
this is going to be an epic battle
between these two competitors and we're
going to be here to call all the action
absolutely youth versus experience and
this lady is all about experience indeed
eight-time Champion if she was to win
today she would take a salad dresser as
the single most awarded uh US champion
in history nine titles that's what she's
playing for Anastasia you can she do it
oh that's a good question but we all
know that Irina is a big fighter she
also has lots of experience playing
armaged on matches absolutely as we know
from her yeah
I understand her match with uh um
this video
yes sir have you ever played this type
of playoffs yes Armageddon games yeah
well
I'm a getting games I'm not really too
sure but playoffs for sure lots and lots
of playoffs I have to think about them
and they are very youthful very excited
Jennifer you because as we know she lost
that 12th game to Arena and she thought
the tournament was over as she said
yesterday coming in she's just excited
and happy that she can play
exactly to try again to win the title
she seems to be in a good mood oh very
much so it's like it's happy and there's
a lot of money still up for grabs tell
us about what the playoffs mean so for
the first place the winner will get 40
000 and for the second place
the loser of the match will get 30 000
it means that the difference is ten
thousand days it's really important ten
thousand the title and all of the
bragging rights now Arena starting with
black in the first game when I'm in
these playoff situations
truthfully I like to start with black
why if I'm successful and by successful
I mean I make a draw then I I feel like
I can put pressure on with the white
pieces if I fail and I lose with the
black pieces then I know that with the
white I have to go all out and I can
adjust my strategy so I think it's a
slight advantage to have black but
Christian you jump in What would you
prefer on the other side of uh the coin
lies the fact that if white wins there's
so much pressure on you after that with
the white pieces to actually score a
victory and also the player that just
played wide and will play Black has uh
the knowledge already that yes I have
draw odds and by the way Irena is not
looking for a draw look at her opening
look at her opening now this is I used
to play this this is an old favorite of
mine the chess engines hate uh
black I just know that in my practice
practice it's often that white uh it's
it's surprised just surprised and they
don't handle it well one thing about
this matchup that I think is quite
important especially with this time
control is the fact that Irina Crush has
had absolutely no problems with her time
management in this tournament Jennifer
you on the other hand she had plenty of
problems and in their direct matchup as
well Jennifer was very much down on time
after the opening phase so I think Irena
has probably outfoxed her younger
opponent in the first stages of this
game all right really interesting for me
this G2 G3 by white I just love as black
to play against that system oh I loved
it because uh essentially what I was
trying to do as black was played for the
move F 7 F5 and I always felt that white
had to insert F4 he said simply when I
play F5 you've got to play F4 and then
when you play F4 I get to capture and
open up my bishop and that's a very
interesting uh way the way Irena crush
is playing this one because I very often
see the trackman only but with the
bishop on E7 correct not on G7 and then
the knight from E8 actually jumps
directly to G7 which is my my preferred
method as well yes and here we go so in
my the way I play these uh positions is
black I in my mind I'm thinking F5 F4 is
a serious threat
and white has to play this move F4 so
the idea is if I take on F4 this bishop
is open
exactly and if you take an F5 this
bishop Still Remains closed and that was
just just my Approach was I really liked
these uh positions uh I like to to to do
this for black now here for example a
night
um to F6 uh invites you to capture and
bring like for example let's say I play
Knight F6 here yes would you take on F5
for example for example and I take and
now
yes yes so now you've done a very nice
job you've isolated my Pawn but let me
remind you I've got one little idea in
mind I want to capture a pawn so I have
to defend it somehow if I play B3 I
don't really like this move because I
opened this diagonal a little bit
further right yeah for the diagonal a
little bit further okay yeah
of somehow support the phone now
somebody mentioned that they think that
the move Knight F4 Knight E6 could be a
key issue let's be super aggressive
let's go Knight f496 and give up the C4
yes I don't want to lose any time I'll
I'll give you the pawn I know you're
going to take it yes sir we already know
that
and I got to take that too and uh we get
some position like this no no uh the
question for me is I'm not really
worried that much about this Pawn but
what I am worried about is this uh pawn
and how should I deal with that should I
play no Knight E4 will allow Queen D5 so
Knight E4 I'm I'm really anxious to play
the move Bishop to D4 Jack I'm just a
little bit worried that after Queen D5
the big threat is discovery check and
the night so okay this is uh it's an
interesting Pawn sacrifice right right
in general I don't think she's going to
be thinking about allowing uh this
couple of Trades I think what she wants
is actually open up the C8 Bishop by
playing the move maybe Knight D to F6
but look at this Irene Irene already
spent I think quite a lot of time on the
move after F4 I think she did down to
her last seven minutes wow against nine
minutes so Jennifer we were anticipating
that she's going to have some problems
with her time management but the reverse
is actually reality right now Irina is
struggling to find the best moves in the
position it's one of the most critical
positions though in right now you have
to make the decision what to do with
your Pawn structure it will be very
impactful for the rest of the middle
game so tonight on the alternative uh
move we were looking a moment ago at 98
F7 6 the alternative move in this type
of a formation you're anticipating
putting your knight on D6 yes one of the
good re things about H3 is that after
this move you're almost obliged to uh
play this move uh B7 B6 you simply
cannot lose this Pawn on C5 and no you
start to wonder uh can I assay this move
D6 guys but Arena has to make a move yes
down to her last five minutes you simply
cannot do this early on in the game by
the way
whoa uh we did not anticipate that can't
be a good move no I mean what is the
Knight doing on C7 right on D6 covers
the sixth Square maybe that's the only
reason so you're thinking that in case
of takes okay I don't know maybe it's
not so important like take and by the
way you have to take with the pawn
taking with the rook in my estimation is
a complete strategic disaster because
after F5 this Knight will go to G3 this
Knight will go to E4 and you can simply
resign so you absolutely are required to
take with the pawn and then let's let's
look at this so the difference is the E6
squares Bishop E3 is on the board Bishop
E3
wow okay Bishop B3 very decent move I'm
I
I'm this supporter of the move Bishop E3
she supports the attention also on the
board and she kind of invites the arena
to make her decisions by herself exactly
and her plan is very easy she wants to
go Queen D2 rook ae1 and put some more
pressure additional pressure in the
center now we do have captures
that is that now 96 is not a threat
anymore
no I don't know it's how important is
this yes let's say okay I go Knight
takes F4 because well I want to go
Knight takes F4 I'm assuming 95 and
because I'm a pond Grabber and I don't
like the move B3 I'll defend the pawn on
C4 in the most natural way Queenie too
now in case you do too yes I'm very
excited with a pawn did she really no
maybe with the night or with the bishop
with a bishop with the bishop so she
played Bishop B3 and then took was the
bishop on F4 this is that cannot be uh
good that's confirmly accurate okay her
idea is that after 95 which was played
she's uh keeping the Knight on C3
protected because I'm almost for sure
her intention is to play B3 she played
in she played it yes okay and so there's
no there's no trick yes D7 he's on the
board
yeah okay to play B5 so there's no way
I'm gonna let this Knight have a nice
life with the move B7 B5 I'm gonna play
A4 to stop B5 and I will live with the
Knight on B4 right this is what why
Jennifer took with the bishop she's
thinking the best minor piece is black
Bishop East G7 so she's setting up for
ideas of Bishop either Bishop to G5 or
Bishop to H6 trying to eliminate that
now I'm not a big fan of the bishop
takes I like the Knight
that was much more pleasing
when summer was played so so she didn't
play B5 no she did not play A4
yeah that's what I mean
immediately played B5
right look at this I mean I think it's
really sharp position it's everything
looks like well I think it's a good
position right now
black is doing great because
this is a wonderful piece this is a
wonderful piece this is okay five GTX 5
is on the board e takes f5g takes F5
yeah she couldn't take maybe with the
bishop because B5 was hanging right so
didn't want to allow something to land
on e4 so she took with the pawn uh
taking control of it I like a little bit
of a compromise I like this idea though
because also you have to worry about
your G3 Pawn now that the pawn is
already on H3 and potentially I can have
ideas of King h8 Rook G8 and open up the
G file try to put pressure on that side
now also this uh last move GTX F5 opens
up the G6 Square potential for my knight
to go there of course not right now
because you have to worry about the D6
spawn but in the future Knight G6 might
become a reality and that will open up
my monster on G7 well let's let's deal
with the monster let's deal with the C4
Pawn first she took on B5 now it takes
B5 and now let's get rid of that monster
I really don't like that that Dragon
Bishop breathing down the board Rook ae1
is on the board Rook AE how can she do
that well she has to play fast though
because actually she's down on time you
remember when she was up four minutes
yes
almost no yes see the problem with this
move Rook on A1 to E1 is you're not
absolutely sure that the Rook is best
placed there but you know with absolute
certitude this bishop is the strongest
piece so we have six wanna play yeah no
there is no more I really understands
that immediately yeah she jumped at that
opportunity and again uh because now I
am getting a little bit
um concerned I want to say that the
Knight on Jesus ignite takes C3 Knight
takes C3 Knight G6 it can be a threat it
can be a threat but I start to worry
okay with Queen DeForest let's get some
tactics Queen G6 and let's get some
tactics flowing ooh you want to get
Knight to foreign correct so I go Rook
F7 Knight to four Queen H6 where do you
put the bishop well that's the question
I was thinking you could take the pawn
but then I had I had uh ah take on G3
but you immediately suggested Queen H6
and where is the bishop going and you're
making a very good point if I have to go
back to H4 I'm not a happy camper all
right uh well Queen F6 and again why did
she put her Rook on E1
I don't know I mean maybe she wants to
put some pressure on this Knight on the
five but at the moment it's still not
easy to do beautifully this is looking
good for Irena right now I have to say
it seems like the momentum has shifted
from the opening when white was putting
pressure on black structure and right
now black has a more Dynamic pieces
and if she wins with the black pieces
and goes on to the second game with the
white pieces and rods well she's going
to be the cleaner all she needs is a
draw she's going to be
honesty three yeah I'm thinking the move
Knight C3 to D1 that's what she makes
the most sense here I'm again I'm not a
big fan of these kind of retreating
moves but this Knight on B5 was
threatening to capture and then it would
be a tactical Target after 96. A5 A5 oh
interesting very quickly played by Arena
too but she's putting a lot of pressure
on her opponent's time right now I
thought about move Knight D4 actually I
don't know why
it's on the board as well she might be
forced to go 94. maybe so but okay then
you check then you have this phone I
don't know if I'm not sure if it's good
for black but maybe we can just try like
94 Knight takes CD4
enjoyed it yes like I would have been a
little bit more reluctant I would have
probably brought my knight back Pawn on
b3's week in any case she's getting
she's playing very dynamically is Irina
I like the way she plays now with this
Knight before idea exactly it's really
hard to win this Pawn on D4 like I don't
see the way because Queen cannot take of
course Knight F3 the only way to try
that is to go King King H1 but then
maybe 96 yes right yes King H1 to uh I
kind of liking well not that I like King
H1 but night night
okay this is not going well for Jennifer
I tried to go to D3 it's it's but I
cannot say it's that bad right but B3
yes but B3 you still don't have a
majority on this side even if you win
that pawn on B3 and in the meantime for
example Rook to B8 I think was played at
58. very nice move Knight to D3 what
they do now I'm starting to like white
to be honest Knight to D3 right to G6
Knight to G6 and then I just defend my
B2 Pawn somehow and or perfectly B4
and try to land the Knight on C6 well I
definitely don't want to see Knight
takes E5 and Bishop takes it I'm trying
to Revolution still again
G6 okay let me try to find some tactics
in the position you could play your move
B4 that does hang a pawn over here it
does and I'm thinking I want to take the
two Bishops so let's not give you the
two Bishops first let's go Bishop G5
drop back with the queen no threat to
take the pawn of course not yet
and now just simply Define that pawn
somehow but by the way
Rook came back to EA okay so that's a
little bit of a logic glitch there and
recognizes her mistake yeah she had to
blame me with the other but then a five
bone was hanging yeah it's time well
time is definitely a factor but what is
the clock times three minutes and 20
seconds for Irina only 2 minutes and 49
for Jennifer
A1 that's what I was saying about Rook
on A1 to E1 is The Rook are you always
sure that that's the best Square for the
road imagine if the dark Square Bishops
were off at the board at the moment you
can imagine that white has a much nicer
life Knight F4 and other ideas but Rook
B8 on the board
um
invent guys Rook to C7 let's go
Rook to C7 I suspect Queen d8 what about
another one it's getting wild it's
getting very very scary
I like Rook C7 guys
B3 Knight takes E5 okay here I'll do
something else I'll take immediately
I'll take immediately
I guess what I got for you this six yes
but it's 67 67 Bishop C8 on the board so
she didn't play uh okay she decided to
keep her Queen now there are ideas of
Bishop takes in Rook C6 I know that if
you ever play E4 it's Splat I'm losing
but uh I start to think how can I
exploit this moment
no yes Bishop G5 is a is
I still can't play Knight F4 not yet yes
but you can uh prepare that with the
move H4 after that perhaps that's an
idea I kind of like Bishop G5 followed
by Knight C1 no this cannot be good
that's not the right direction well it
it it it does two things it does avoid
Bishop A6 and it does defend the
weakness but you're right the Knight is
not a happy camper on C1 it's just a
defensive but okay maybe she wants to
just to take the bone now it's about
nerves uh I mean the position's double
edged which of these two ladies will
hold their nerves the best Queen takes
A5 you know Arena has such an
experienced player she's saying I don't
want to be down upon should I play the
move right before for example just to
stop the threats so let's take a look at
the times right now guys again
let's get a glimpse at
that one minute and nine seconds for
Jennifer against two minutes and 30
seconds for Irena Irena has built up a
very nice time Advantage but it can be
gone very soon if you don't make it move
uh I would I dropped Rook B4 on the
board in a heartbeat I would just be
very very happy she's going for it Rook
before he's on the board yeah the same
move faster is a little now the question
is what is white going to do because
from White's perspective this Bishop's
kind of maximized maybe you play King H2
because you're just not sure what you're
supposed to do rookie one Rook E1 once
again it just doesn't feel like that's
the right
okay I'm looking at D3 that pawn could
be very very nice I agree Knight takes
D3 Knight takes place
I think she decided to protect her Rook
on the eight or something like that so
goes back to situ oh he's getting wild
yeah
very inspired chess right now King aged
kind of perplexed but not really Knight
to three is still possible sometimes yes
you kind of think that maybe King H1 but
okay
D3 yeah
that really feels like the money moved
where is she going
um the question is what is white oh Rook
C6 Rook C6
there is a it is a tactic that's Rook C6
C6 yeah
and I think she sees it yes she was
really trying to understand if it's like
again remind everybody it's 10 minutes
and only two seconds that's 20 seconds
left guys
and you didn't find it this is it wow
oh wait but D3 now D3 is an automatic
trade queens and pushed the pawn might
actually be very painful right now okay
these three is a really uh was Rook C6
or 66 was winning wow do you disagree
Bishop E3 came immediately by the way no
time Rook C6 was plus seven
plus seven
oh that's the second time that you don't
know it's just a pawn you lose the pawn
on D6 and after that all of your
everything
it's Irina who's on the offense so Queen
B7 she played and two yes Queen B7 Rook
D2 on the board 20 seconds for Jennifer
one minute and five seconds for Irena
that minute and five I tell you it takes
down but that 20 seconds but what do you
know for for black F5 is hanging
okay the bishop I was about to say I
thought the bishop was much better
placed on the F4 Square than on the E3
Square she just did that as a um
Tempo 40 seconds for Irina 20 seconds
for General okay now
G6 at some point okay it will be a chip
Blade with the idea to maybe move her
Knight yes exchange and get back with
the other Rook on EA now that the pawn
on A5 is not true
decision huge decision right Bishop
takes E5 Bishop takes E5 Knight takes D3
no you gotta get rid of that pawn that
pawn on D3 is just but I'm afraid about
some F4 ideas you know like take on D3
and then F4 because now if you take on
the four Bishop before Queen the four
okay one that's clear maybe but there
are some g3s yes so you have to check
also the Knight takes D3 attacks the
bishop Bishop she took it she she went
for the Bishops of opposite colors
between h8 she decided to make this
reflective move in order to have a four
idea for the time for the video
right now because there's no way we're
going to keep up with them right now yes
yeah we're going into the last 10
seconds yes
so she decided to sacrifice her Rook for
the bishop and uh this reason on the
boardwalk F7 and what queen F6 was the
threat yesterday
Queen F7 right now
is Queen F7 just simply winning
check in Queen F7
look at this queen of seven where's the
check you don't have any checks anymore
yes and this is over
oh my gosh H7
oh
my goodness wow she finds Queen F7 and
takes it all the way to the back oh whoa
this is unbelievable and there was no
defense because Queen j8 was another
threat right at this moment so like if
you try to defend it with the queen
right wow I lost
connection
is right now of course a sign of
experience she knows that her position
was better at this moment but she still
has one more chance to get back in this
match but Jennifer rookie five what a
great idea you know to give your Rook
for that
exactly well just to review everybody
Jennifer will now defend the black
pieces and Irina is in a must-win
situation it's really that simple I
think it's the way this game to come
back to the uh
I mean we're just well we're not that
far away but I just felt like the
tension is the playoff it was jittery
and and again uh Jennifer takes the
first playoff and Arena will have to
bounce back with a win uh could we
review the last 15 moves on your board
uh what the heck happened because I got
a feeling that was a hot potato going
back and forth Christian no absolutely I
mean this was the big moment right here
the first big moment of this match when
Jennifer could have just simply one in
one move with a move uh Rook to C6 now
apparently the engine is saying that you
have to go well and keep it and just
give up the bishop actually the bishop
is less important than the pawn on D6
for example if you go Queen to B7 after
root takes D6 everything falls in the
position Rook to E6 is a huge threat in
the position I'm also threatening to
take and then follow it up with Queen to
G5 this is looking bad for a black this
was a huge moment and after what she
played Queen to F2 this actually gives
the advantage to Black after the move D3
and let's take a look at where Irina
went wrong perhaps Queen to D7 was a bit
too passive take only five take on D3
was taking on D3 the right decision yes
okay yes yes you have to eliminate the
Knight and you have to save the dark
Square Bishop uh in the position can you
check this a four move immediately
instead of King shade like pure F4 and
yes I think I just take it maybe you're
losing yes but I just wanted to because
of uh three years and Queenie one yes I
think to G3 and then Queen to uh F6 yes
yes
[Laughter]
good move by Irina I really like this uh
but the problem is right now they're
on equal footing when it came to uh
their time so now Rook takes E5 was that
was great yeah and perfectly timed and
right now it is white who has the
initiative and in fact after Rook to F7
Queen D6 she found the right sequence
wow yes Queen to F7 very easy to gain a
couple of seconds Rook to B2 you can
give one check but where's your next
check wow you would love to go to B1
unfortunately that Bishop will capture
that let's take a look at the end in
slow motion it was this uh
Queen F's that was the big move nicely
found Bishop 24. by the way that Bishop
really is somewhere big between E4 and
E3 and uh so they repeat it once once
but now comes the the money move right
here check and cleanliness I wonder if
Irina real of course yeah queen of seven
sighting and now like there is no way to
spent after that like you cannot play
Queen H6 because Queen G8 is the threat
so she tried her last chance but okay
Queen H7 yeah
very unpleasant moment of course right
for arena and pleasant for Jennifer's
house
the opening gamble if you will because
uh it paid off paid off it did I mean
Arena did have the advantage out of the
opening but uh Jennifer somehow in that
time scramble outplayed her wow more
experienced upon him she had less time
at certain point right absolutely
absolutely everything was going smooth
for Irina when she was up on time right
and I think this is critical to this
matchup she needs to put pressure on her
opponent's time as fast as possible as
early as possible in the game and we
know right now Irina is probably outside
talking with her coach oh never mind
never mind back at the board because the
games are just about to start Jennifer
just needs to make a draw and she's a
winner of the U.S Championship
absolutely that's what it's all about
not a bad position to be not at all not
at all and there's the heart handshake
to start this round too again
I mean for arena she's gotta win and the
slav defenses oh Exchange
I mean to put all your marbles on the
exchange sloth I guess it means that
Arena didn't have any particularly uh
good
ideas or prep for the slav exchange slop
is really considered a very equal uh way
of playing these days for white
yes Bishop B5 sure well I'm not a big
fan of this exact uh
choice because I'm thinking Queen B6
right and then you don't want to take my
knight but Queen B6 attacks the bishop
but then after Knight C3 A6 B2 is
hanging it'll end up having to give me
the bishop anyway
yeah
but she they actually it served her well
yesterday in the game against it she's
the queen this type of positions no that
of course he's Knight C3 right nothing
nothing to do there but 94 what she
wants to play I think 94 Bishop D7
Bishop D7 first okay so that just kind
of makes Bishop take C6 and no go so
Irina in a must-swing situation went for
the exchange slav right it means that
she didn't have preparation for it she
didn't she didn't expect
this line of play yeah yeah but I do
believe that Jennifer is a slav player
isn't she
I think she plays quite a few times in
this story yes yes
but uh sometimes you you know your
opponent is going to play the Berlin yes
but you don't have anything prepared I
mean you just uh
you've got a place and that's it that's
it you just see what what kind of but
Jennifer doesn't play the Berlin
exactly and actually she came and gave
us some interviews and she was saying
that I don't really know what to play
against E4 and she had some problems in
this tournament against one E4 so a bit
of a confounding uh idea by Irina Crush
in the opening phase and by the way even
though the slav is really one of the
most solid defenses been played for
centuries in FL in fact they're in a
position that's unique to my database
the combination of Bishop F4 Bishop B5
they may transpose but at this moment no
games in my database after the move
Knight E2
Queen A5 seems to have been the novelty
in this game nevertheless I mean the
position remains very very rather
standard position it's a standard
position yeah now after uh I mean again
if you're gonna put the bishop on D7 the
idea is you want to question the bishop
and you want to play the move A7 A6 and
probably I will have to drop back to d
33 to T3 exactly Bishop back to D3 now
the question is should I go and try to
hunt this bishop down like for example
something like Knight here I have a
question for you guys though why did she
put her Knight on E2
probably just decided to over protect
her night on system maybe she was a
little bit worried that if she goes
Knight f394 maybe something I mean
perhaps otherwise I don't have a clear
answer 92 kind of neutralizes 94. you
can even go back Bishop D3 yeah but in
general the Knight on E2 is not best
placed in fact black very often plays
the move Bishop to G4 early on in the
opening to try to force the move Knight
to e to to defend the queen on that
diagonal you definitely want Knight E5
Knight F3 and 95 is a typical uh
placement for the night and by the way
after Knight E2 E7 E6 came quickly
castles now the inclusion of Queen A5
really I have to question that inclusion
if you're playing Queen A5 to play
Knight E4 I get it if you're playing
Queen A5 to provoke Knight C3
you're helping your pieces exactly yeah
and after castles A6 Bishop D3 Bishop E7
A3
if I were in
um Arena shoes there I might have
preferred h2h3 you want to keep this
bishop alive I do yes I do I also like
this idea I think it's a very good
Bishop that kind of reaches into Black's
position Five played by a journey for
and now I feel like finally Irena has to
go for E4
I feel she has to go for this uh break
right now and of course if you want you
need to win this game you really need to
play something with pressure on your
opponent and your opponent just weakened
her night on C6 well for me I I would
probably take it a different step
because I liked what you said that the
Knight really belongs on F3 why because
then I can jump to E5 after I see the
move B5 I see this move Knight to C1
where the ideas of jumping to C5 now
should I start with B4 though I think
you have to yeah if you want to play
this idea Knight C1 and I'm Dreaming I
have a dream now you're gonna you're
gonna probably no no no no no no
cancel your dream yeah how do we do that
let's go Castle first yes right and that
might be three night A5
I think she played Knight C1 it might be
one what what
excuse me what is Knight B1 A3 hold on
we have hey
91 Queen B6 Knight D2 is on the board
okay same idea of but too long it's it's
a it's a long maneuver that is for sure
Queen B6 Knight D2 on the board doesn't
make the more sense to my eyes well okay
it feels too slow it does it feels very
very slow but again slow but certain she
is heading for the C5 Square Knight B3
Rook C1 Knight C5 on Arena's uh agenda I
like also Knight C1 because in this case
Knight H5 was not possible anymore and
you don't need even to spend time for
move H3 but now I mean again black has
always this option to take the bishop
seemed to really like a good move
okay
um again uh for those of you joining as
late shame on you uh secondly arena is
in a must-win situation with the white
pieces because she's lost the first game
we're in the second tiebreak game and I
really like this move by Jennifer very
much Knight A5 in a sense White's
approach is kind of
mono maniacal one idea put the Knight on
C5 well Jennifer says first of all if
you put your knight on B3 I can take it
but I also have a square this Square C4
I'm going to try to put a knight on C4
before you get your knight to C5 and I
really like this decision a lot and
actually Jennifer is playing Super Quick
in this one and I have to say I'm
impressed with her time management six
minutes and 59 seconds against 5 minutes
and 54 seconds a difficult position
right now to be in for the eight-time
national champion Irina Crush because
right well I mean her dreams right now
of obtaining an opening Advantage are
shattered at this point she doesn't have
anything in the position and she will
have to pull a rabbit out of her head to
actually win this game exactly now
unfortunately for Jennifer after this
very strong move Knight A5 she's gonna
have to fall back on a decision maybe
she doesn't she might come to regret but
if you don't play E3 E4 there's really
nothing for you in the position
I thought about it like not C4 and now
Knight B3 this is the idea what she's
going for wow
the night on C4 certainly makes a very
pleasing impression tonight to B3 okay
the Knight gets to C5 but
she has to play fast though
does
Irina maybe the difference is that white
has some ideas with even not to not see
fire to play for sometimes and black
it's really hard for black to push E5 at
least at the moment it's time for
Jennifer to Castle perhaps absolutely
most likely see something along the
lines of Knight of C5
I don't really want to entomb my Rook
with a move like Bishop E8 so I would
probably but you're not actually
threatening my Bishop so let's move
right yeah but I I'm more of I'm more in
the line that I want to play a6a5 and
therefore I'm thinking that with my
Bishop on C6 I'll support a capture on
A1 yeah followed by Rook to A8 you're
right I could start with Rook C8 But
there again I want I'm one of those
saying am I absolutely sure the Rook is
the best Square yeah so Knight C5 is on
the board guys castles Knight C5 yes
expecting Bishop C6 but also if if I can
get away with A5 immediately I would
find that move as well as Bishop C6 the
most attractive right now they're
basically even on time Jennifer has
spent quite a few uh minutes on her last
couple of moves Bishop takes C5 huge
decision
for Wow
for me no way no way Jose this is a very
strange decision I don't like that
decision I would play D take C5
heartbeat she played it and then after
Queen B7 I would play Bishop takes C4 in
a heartbeat with the idea of playing
Bishop E5 and Knight D4 Bishop C2 she's
going forward
24 ideas of Queen to D3 in the position
ship C2 so she's kind of encouraging E5
right
E5 looks good right now absolutely E5
looks good and maybe after the move
Bishop to G3 ideas of Bishop G4 Bishop
H5 Bishop G6 to cover up the king side
and make a
iterate to try H6 H6 how are we doing on
time five
six okay that stops Bishop G5 but
I thought E5 and in case of Bishop g594
was the way to go H oops excuse me that
was my mouse slip
24 years old yes
oh no
53.3 yes really oh yeah that's not
Checkmate E5 what about D5 I'm all for
it E5 and I liked I liked your your uh
decision there to try to neutralize this
bishop on C2 with ideas of Bishop h54
right now
after Bishop G4 Bishop page four oh I
have to play G5 no nothing to do about
it and now wait wait the answer go back
go back go back I'm gonna try to get
adventurous for a second three or four
yes and four four I like it I'm not
saying it works
okay sure because you can probably take
on the tour and do what you'll do the
thing is it's not my pieces
it's the commentators
it's it's the commentators
um benefit we get to throw pieces and
then take all of our moves back E5 is on
the board Bishop G3
G6 G6 okay well this is also a very
direct approach but
she wants to play Bishop F5
and captures uh one question I always
ask when you play the move G7 G6 do you
have a dark Square Bishop
I I have
you're right now
uh you that's a consequences
I always remember by the way by the way
the dark squared Bishop well that's what
she's asking right now Queen C3 thread
in Bishop E5
I think I can go ideas of f4 in fact F4
H4 yeah
F4 is really a very powerful question is
that a move what about this we do have
rookie eight on the board pardon me no I
mean E3 Square becomes weak I don't know
but yeah but you cannot use it uh
F7 Check Yes definitely problematic yes
okay so maybe she should do it with
another look
so a big moment then big decision for
Irena right now four no I'm I'm playing
F4 because I want to blast open this
bishop now let me have to start
calculating ideas of Knight to G4 Knight
to G4 I'm happy about Knight to G4
because again I'm just opening up the
dark squares
yes I'm just saying that this I I'm I'm
happy with I'm a little bit worried
about D4
this is a more of a kind of a a
positional Pawn sacrifice where the
Knight could be very absolutely what
away okay three okay
she doesn't want to burn Bridges exactly
there is this combination of really you
know sharp hard move like G7 G6 and E5
and then the soft move like F3 uh from
Arena I'm not really sure uh they fit I
like F4 I like that four times three
exactly yeah I think the idea is to go
eliminate the Knight on C4 and then you
still have problems with the pawn on E5
you think something like Bishops
[Music]
well I would be kicking this bishop back
Bishop C6 to C6
I was going to say I will be kicking
this bishop away from G3 and
may be going okay pardon me I think her
idea is to defend the king side with her
Queen I mean I would be thinking of
maybe trying to trade because of History
yes
and she played Bishop to B3 no Queen E7
seems to be the right solution
again Knight G3 Knight h57 on the board
I think she wants to also protect laid
that kind of quickly is uh time travel
beginning to rear it's ugly head two
minutes and 50 seconds for both players
they're okay in terms of their times
Venture again uh it's going to come down
to a nerves this move Queen E7
I you know I love to try to play Bishop
H4 induce G5 so that I can one day bring
my knight to
g3.58 so now Bishop [ __ ] first like
she's asking for this movement but then
she's going to go G5 she has to respond
with G5 okay that's what I'm saying I
mean I'm fine with that yes you know
Bishop to Bishop to H4 G5 Bishop to G3 I
still don't know what my two Bishops are
doing but at least I have a plan of
planting my knight on a beautiful
Outpost she's done going for it
now the position becomes extremely
destabilized
oh she doesn't break the pin at once
I thought she had to go for it and then
go G4 actually follow it up with G4 G3
okay G5 and G4 F4 is it possible now uh
fortnite E4 I think is a problem
Knight e44 yes um also the small problem
with F4 is I'm always cognizant of the
move D5 D4 even at the point at the cost
of a pawn that Bishop could be really
really dangerous once you've played the
move F4 unfortunately
dropping to her last one minute and 30
seconds I think it's still two minutes
and 45 seconds on her clock I think it's
time for A4 A4 open up the a files so
The Rook could land on A6 and the clock
yeah it's getting scary we could be
seeing the last moments of this
Championship right now can Arena Force
an Armageddon with a victory I'm sure
she's got to play A4
yes
I don't know I mean that's why now she
decided not to do it discretion the part
I don't know I like the bishop on H4 I
thought it was time to play A5 I think
Arenas being far too cage passive yes
yes yes maybe she doesn't want really
it's it's difficult to find the right
strategy at this moment like yeah shall
I keep the position and wait for my
opponent to do a mistake or the fact
that Jennifer just needs to draw maybe
also like can affect her play she
doesn't want to risk also and A4 yes
finally she goes for the plan that you
were recommending yes but I was
recommending at a time when the bishop
was on H4 and here I'm a little bit of
everything why not why not
I mean it sure would be nice wouldn't it
here in this moment I probably would
trade on A4 even at the cloud because
I'm thinking this Pawn is a little bit
weak so imagine I take take take
C A5 ooh oops
28.
I think she should have taken maybe
perhaps she wants to take with the
bishop and get the Knight to C6 I like
that idea very much well but I would
have done it I I would have wanted the
Knight on C5 by the way uh right now I
think the times are getting very close
to being so again we're thinking takes
takes the night will be very comfy on
the C6 square but then you have to worry
about the E4 sometimes yes and with the
idea to kind of ask questions you're
asking questions you're asking all the
right Questions
AB Bishop B5 nonetheless
if you go E4 there
well then I could that is a nasty pin
maybe in all times go F4
wow correct but I'm not sure that works
well we're playing Knight C6 regardless
it feels like you have to go Knight C6
right yep
that's no no
Queen she's okay I can't guess the movie
I simply can't guess the move she wants
to meet E4 with D4 yes
93.9 guys 30 seconds last few seconds
[Laughter]
is an option
um maybe she missed something I'm not
sure about D4 Bishop takes D4 and Knight
D4 and then Bishops oh that's fine D
four is four she takes immediately
yes the bishop with some ideas Bishop a
Chase so she's saying the Knight is
trapped on C4 what that's hard to
believe maybe she's got a point
you got to play Rook takes D4 and we
know that Jennifer likes to give her her
Rooks for Bishops so yeah there we go
she's reaching with 20 seconds yes
Rook D3 what is that Rook D3 Rook D3
Queen B2 Rook by three goddess well
Bishop to D5 oh my God
and defend the Knight on E5 no this is
looking good for black right yes Rook D5
I think is winning yeah okay
there's a mate coming F6 Queen takes F6
oh my gosh four seconds queen of seven
the only move four seconds three seconds
oh my God four three this is not over
yet guys it's gonna be interesting
oh that comes one second oh my gosh you
almost flagged three seconds right now
rookie one now and what's going on Rook
is seven maybe 92 I don't know the moves
oh
oh Knight takes Queen E5 I think now
Queen E8 and uh rookie seven Queen d8
queen queen
of Fate queen of Fate is still no
yes and she forces the Armageddon
[Laughter]
that was nerves and like and wow what a
game I mean what a turn of events when
we came before we came on the show you
were saying Anastasia that you were
having coffee with a lot of ladies
and don't worry you'll see an Armageddon
yes exactly yes everybody was like kind
of trying to predict what will happen
and we came to conclusions that both of
these ladies are great Fighters and it's
gonna bear my goodness
we had coffee nearby and like we were
trying to guess how it will go there I
would say good guesswork
as uh take us through that very very
nervous finals but first of all again
the playoff is one to one yes one one we
have and we're going to see there my
ghetto game five minutes to White four
for black and uh wait this is the
never-ending Story the tournament just
keeps going and going and going
everybody
yeah right what was going on when did
how did the valuations change it was
swinging it was all over the place take
a look at this at this point very nicely
timed The Exchange sacrifice with Rook
takes D5 and right now after Rook 2 you
want Knight to C4 was a decisive mistake
in fact she was supposed to go Knight
bc6 put some pressure on D4 and right
now this pretty much forces this way but
let's take a look at the Lots
be two seconds increment in effect for
move 61 onwards okay if we're going to
set up a little modern on the other
computer so you can both see this
display but a little closer to you okay
uh Jennifer since uh Irina
about to do the other one you will do
the coin toss uh whoever wins needs to
immediately people everything online or
block okay uh heads and details go ahead
and call
um
you're correct it's ahead
yes there was a reason Armageddon in the
rapid and Blitz I think it was between
Fabi and Ali Raza and Fabi chose white
yes and it played out and I remember yes
Christian was not sure if it was the
best choice at the time but anyway like
Jennifer chooses black and she kind of
stays with this choice that if I make a
draw I'm going to become a champion Now
remind our viewers about the Armageddon
What crispr just said it's five minutes
to four minutes in terms of the starting
times with no increment for the first 60
moves yes but following the 61st move
then the players get a bonus two seconds
two seconds for each move and in case of
a draw black wings black wins it's that
simple and did you like Jennifer's
choice I think it's uh yeah it's a brave
Choice she will get had viciously
attacked you can add on that because
Irena will be coming with some very
interesting ideas I don't think we're
going to see once again this exchange
love but who knows let's just wait and
see it's true
and let's see the end of the game uh
using our magic of television in slow mo
this is where she should have played
Knight to to bc6 activate the last piece
in the position and this is where I
forgot that the bishop actually defends
The Rook I thought she just blundered
Nate that's what we hope Bishop h8
threatens Queen G7 that was in seven
seconds that wasn't nice and that
stopped Jennifer Jennifer take down it
looked till three it looked like she's
Queen takes F6 Queen F7
right here Irina played her move with
one second let's take a look at this
look at this two one two oh no not
nothing this one with two seconds but
the next one
but this is where Jennifer this is the
one this is visual one second yes
by the way she played also with one
second yesterday against Sanders when
she saw 31 seconds
for half a second that was a from the
end of this tournament we were half a
second away from the end of the sword oh
my God now 90 I didn't like that move I
thought the Knight should have come back
now here it comes this is going to be
the ten thousand dollar move coming up
uh Queen F7 Queen d8 She should play
Queen at eight yes because keeping in
mind The Rook E8 is protected the
position is still lost even after that
but it's the best way to fight yes seven
was the best move yes and then Irina
forced I mean I would still place two
pieces against Queen
I would have played it for a while oh
boy oh boy
nerves and you can see the laptop right
now in front of them so that the players
know when they reach 61 moves oh really
yes wow I didn't know that that's why
they have it that's why they posted that
laptop there
that's interesting I I've never seen
that me too yes that's for me unique
because but you know what to remove
repetitions maybe for 60 move but you
know what why because one of the players
has Vision towards the Monitor and the
other doesn't so one player has the
advantage you can see the monitor on the
wall the big monitors
when they reach 61 moves but the other
player cannot see
so okay I see what you mean the monitor
is there you see the monitor behind yes
right
so Jennifer with black pieces can see
that Irena cannot unless she watches the
laptop I see okay
as we get ready for game I'm just uh
that's a pretty nice table by the way
for that laptop
we've got a front row seat huh I wonder
if there's a webcam on the laptop
and there we go guys and are we going to
C5 yes
by the way Jennifer has to play Fast she
has one last minute on her clock as we
start the game and there is no increment
right
right now we're expecting either D3 okay
now white can challenge that center with
the move C4 but that allows D takes C4
and the exchange of the Queens she
decided against it E4 right right now
before he's taking her first thing
funnily enough I get these positions
with Kara Khan's with the pawn on C6 and
I get to play H6 and Bishop E6 and guess
what we're almost into a Czech benoni
remember that first game with reverse
Scholars with the reverse colors I was
expecting C5 there I'm expecting F5 yes
whoa what what just happened whoa she
moved her vision
that's the blunder of a bishop in one
move wow I cannot believe it wow
uh what a moment
wow what to say queen G4 Bishop G4 Queen
takes G4 she's just blundered bishop and
once
you let go of that Bishop it's over
right it's touch move but it's when the
game really say hey let me it's just
like I put the bishop back on the bishop
back nothing on an official game no that
will be it will be great to see this
moment later to understand like how oh
my God what the tragedy actually yes I
mean this is crazy I know all Irena has
to do is trade trade trade gather her
nerves and and and just slow down
and finish the job yeah it's just trade
trade trade uh she's a piece it's
something
and there's no light Square Bishop for
black zero compensation and right now
Irina might be looking at her ninth
title exactly
Bishop to D2 this one we couldn't
predict no and then like yeah how the
fortunes can change in just a minute in
a second
like you make a move and you lose 10 000
that's hurtful now have you ever
experienced it felt
if there's a possibility of making a
mistake in chess I've done it twice
because I wasn't sure it was it was a
bad mistake the first time very good
move by Arena of course just trade
everything she's doubled Rooks properly
on the open file and you can drive play
Queen H5 in this position can't I take
twice on it three times on F5
that's that's that's winning yeah yeah
that's a beautiful way Bishop takes Pawn
takes Rook takes that is a great
followed by Queen G4 all I want to do is
just trade trade trade and make sure
that I have an extraction but I think
four something else G4 also like uh but
G4 Knight D6 has to be played right
right
I don't know about this move G4
what a picture a little bit around my
king What A peculiar move I know I mean
Bishop takes H5 Bishop takes F5 and
queen H5
but 96 96 you have to play 96 um okay
okay do we have Knight takes D6 or do we
blunder
Bishop takes H2 I think she played it
is on the board makes it a little bit
confusing I mean you do get a lot of
pieces for that Queen uh that is true
but a piece versus I mean I would never
have gone through this I will not win
this game I mean it's something you make
suicide exactly
this is this is very confusing everybody
this is not this is the way you hear
more guys you're supposed to win a piece
I'm not easy anymore okay two let's try
to count everything no no Rook ah Rook
H2 you want yeah so what for example and
then maybe Rook takes F7 but then you
take on D6
on E2 okay King takes H2 is on the board
but we see Queen takes D6
it's equal now I can't believe it no the
position is equal now no way
unbelievable what does Arena doing I
think again it's nerves it's just you
cannot express are you kidding me no
this you can't explain what Arenas is
that you you take on F5 and you go Queen
H5 even if you don't see Queen G4 you do
not play G4 and allow these types of
ticks and she's a minute ahead on the
clock right now no way remember there's
no increment up until move 16 why is
this equal what should what black do
well why do right now is the question
she's gonna move her King let's say King
to G1 King to G1 and then I take your
queen and I have to take the Rook on
King to H1
so now she got a rook and two Bishops
it's not over white still has something
five Check Yes
you have to be careful not to get
checkmated if you start hunting for
pawns probably Jennifer doesn't want to
exchange Rooks but I'm not sure if it's
possible okay now because it seems like
Irena might still be winning
she's back to her well sorry what
happened I'm asking you where was the
where was we will see that after the
game
[Laughter]
he's helping me I remember when she
played this move Queen D5 now probably
when she played Queen D5 she was
supposed to actually play Queen G3
invade via G3 G5 protecting the pawn on
you I like that this is a good move and
probably now she wants to play like Rook
F2 then make her Bishops acting it's
it's all about the time right now guys
something like that
yeah because no increment there's no
increment and this is a change between
D1 this is only move 28 Arena she did
play Rook
g21 why did she do this this is
she needs to play but fast move but now
Black's King when it was in a potential
mating that now has the opportunity to
get out of but do you get out because I
go rookie to after King F7
I try to uh slow you down
true I can zooky two and then how do you
get your queen out
what do you want so quickly there's
three what now Bishop BH wants to play I
don't know I don't know what she wants
to play but she has two wow and Bishop
of course you have to make your pieces
active Okay uh but black just helped
white enormously
Bishop 55 is a kind of a mating thread
is that a Checkmate almost no no
Rook F7 guys but she has 23 seconds
She's Gotta play H5 no then it's working
it's game over this is just winning
we've got three seconds 25 moves though
she used to play Samsung Queen is three
maybe 23 seconds for 25 moves she needs
to play Fast whatever happens next but
it's amazing it should be it's me or
queen E8 yes what uh
why is she not going Rook F7
Bishop B5 or B one minute right now now
she's threatening to go
um
King h8 King h8 the only move only by
the way times are equal almost right now
come on Jennifer King h8 the only move
he has planking in shade king of one
what's his idea maybe bishop B1 Bishop
D2 or something to E3 she has to play
Fast both of them have to check King up
let's go uh Rook of seven retreating go
and 13 seconds 10 seconds Queen C1 check
unbelievable
she's not gonna make it she's 20 moves
away four seconds this is over guys yes
you cannot make this is over check it's
too late for Irina should speed things
up yes that's it that's an illegal move
no I mean that finishes the game no it's
a penalty of two minutes I believe but
it doesn't matter she's 40 moves away
from making 61 moves there's no way with
two seconds she's going to complete all
her moves uh-huh
there's a two-minute penalty yes in
favor of of Jennifer so shall not lose
on time and it means yes before that you
had still some chances
there's no way it's it's 14 moves in two
seconds it's physically impossible to
make the moves and Jennifer oops they
didn't push the button properly yeah so
and now what he pushed well he's just
making sure that it's now we're
expecting oh come on this is G5 this is
over yeah her time has expired and okay
this is really a tragedy this game is
just to be interested I can't believe
what I just saw everybody that was one
of the most remarkable absolutely
so let's put all this together first
Jennifer lost her Bishop just in one
move for nothing for nothing yes and
then Arena didn't manage to win this
game with an extra piece and uh and
ended up losing on time but she was so
after making an illegal for like her
emotions are like she cannot believe
what had just happened oh my goodness we
have a winner
she gave a bishop and still she won this
Championship it's like finished falling
across the Finish Line
I mean I don't even know how to express
this absolutely
she was like you give a peace and still
you win this tournament I'm still
incredible comeback victory for young
Jennifer you okay yes sir
congratulations you pick and also
probably he has heart attack but right I
think both VAR and I are in Shock by
what we just saw with I I mean it's it's
just unbelievable that you're in you're
an entire
a piece ahead and completely winning and
everything that oops excuse me
everything that everything had been
going swimmingly well for 20 moves and
then the wheels came off just after this
moment I mean you can resign this
position and all you do is you take the
night this is the night and then you
take the opponent of course you take the
pawn but if you don't see Queen G4 all
you're trying to do is trade peace
you just keep trading more and more
pieces until you're left with an extra
piece yes instead she played This
Strange move G4 and even after G4 you
could play Rook takes F7 why not Rook
takes F7 Knight takes F7 Queen F3 and
you continue your trading yeah
she took on D6 and now it's absurdly
complicated it's just complicated it you
know it's one of the tricks wow
and and then well let's see the moment
where Jennifer played Bishop G4 so
yeah yes and the crazy part is in the
previous game she played F5
automatically take it back right now
okay this is like normal situation yes
and then she realized oh she's let go of
it so I can actually let go of it
everything so it's possible sometimes in
Blitz it's touch clock your game you you
you your move is completed when you push
the clock it's a button but it's not the
case right but to keep her composure at
this point and finish the game
I mean I cannot it's it's it's just
incredible it's crazy it's crazy then
Arena fought her way back to an
advantage position right here as as uh
as well we're we're in loss for words
yes absolutely
still winning but it was not so easy
anymore right it was already complicated
yes right but okay uh Rook the F7 check
uh she had actually allowed this one
very important move it gives Black's
King some Square h a and H7 so this move
H7 H5 and then after it's all about the
clock yes then they were down to 10
seconds for some ridiculous number 20
moves something like this the Christian
is with the 2022 US Women's Champion
Christian Jennifer first of all huge
congratulations how are you feeling
right now after that Madness that just
ensued over the chessboard I
I just want to apologize for how bad
that game
like there's no way that I lose a U.S
Championship because I hate him Bishop
against Irina twice like I was like
first time bad enough and then I was
just like oh my God it's probably over
and then you know
when there's no increment how did you
manage to get yourself back mentally at
that point after you just played the
move Bishop to G4 and you looked at
Chris bird and did he confirm that yes
it's not only touch move you drop the
piece it's it's done yeah yeah no
because it was like instinct because in
Blitz usually it's like clock me or
something so you're like oh can I do but
and I was like well nothing left to lose
absolutely I was like I was like oh is
it over I might as well just you know
make things a little tricky um I only
had like one chance here and
um and then she played that move G4 and
it felt like she's weakening her King a
little bit and then you managed to find
that Bishop takes H2 on the board did
you feel like once again you're gaining
some chances in the position yeah I
think it's objectively still losing yes
um but I was like you know no increment
um everything is up for grabs and then
um honestly at the very end there it was
all based on flagging like it's kind of
crazy that you know two and a half weeks
of work comes down to those few seconds
but I guess us chess and even in the
second game you are doing quite well
with the black pieces you have draw odds
and at some point she played the move
with one second on her clock did you
realize that no I was probably doing the
same thing I had no idea I was like
keeping an eye out but I was just I
definitely like should not have thrown
the game like that but um I just could
not think anymore I so that was why like
the last game I was just trying to move
fast and you don't even thinking you
just drop a piece was like maybe this
passes on online chess but you know she
just takes it it's like a pre-move
Jennifer you are the US junior girls
Champion 2022 you are the US Women's
2022 Champion how do you feel right now
I mean I have to say I'm a little happy
I feel pretty good
um honestly did not think that I would
pull this off here at this tournament
just because the way I was playing like
I'm not very happy with the quality of
my games and
um like just hanging to the torment and
feel ready I was prepared so
um I honestly didn't know if I could do
it because I knew I like should be able
to because I've done this once before
and once you've done it it just feels so
much easier but it was just
I don't know I just had so many things
going on too like my head was like
completely in the game and then
um I just kept having like a roller
coaster like I would win a few games
yeah and then it was like oh no more
chances but I mean there always were
chances but like in my head I was like
you know time to focus on you know
school or something and then and then I
win again and then I'd be like Oh I'm
back in the game and then you know every
time I'm like so close and then there's
like something happens what were the
types of positions that you were looking
for in this matchup because Irena hasn't
lost a single game up to uh this match
what were the type of positions that you
were looking for I I really just wanted
to get like a dynamic imbalance kind of
position I wasn't I didn't really
prepared to specifically opening wise
because also I knew she was going to
switch things up
um I was just I didn't want like a
really boring like um kind of position
where she can squeeze me because I think
that's like our differences in style
like I'm really good at you know
creating messes I like to create messes
um and I think she like wants the
opposite so that was kind of my goal
guys any questions for our champion
I think we're coming down still Jennifer
I think we've got the butterflies over
here
a big congratulations wow I can't just
win a tournament I have to you know
throw away a few for Content yeah
exactly exactly but wow we were on the
edge of a seat for three games in a row
I have a question like such a you won't
know just right now forty thousand I
mean what are you going to do is such a
great uh price and how are you going to
celebrate today how am I going to
celebrate and how will you spend your
money
I mean I feel you know
I like to buy clothes
also more importantly for me you know
tuition is something big so that helps
cover it but I haven't even thought
about it yet because I just like I feel
like
I don't know I just didn't expect like I
think it's like when you know that it's
possible but you're not sure if it's
gonna happen
um yeah so I have to really think about
that oh I would go to Thai food first
Thai food yeah why not good good
decisions
yeah yes good decision that's great
Jennifer our congratulations really a
remarkable wow Jennifer won two titles
so I just wonder which title like you
feel it's more valuable for you
first time and what which emotions do
you have right now like if you compare
them
well the first time it happened I just
didn't know it was possible
um like I was I had the same situation I
was half a point uh leading going to
second last round didn't even think
about winning
um because I didn't think I could do it
and then it happened so it was a
completely different experience because
it kind of put my open the doorway for
me to be like oh it's possible to you
know win a tournament like this and then
what else could this could this lead to
um so that was something that was really
valuable for me for this one I just
think this was a unique kind of
challenge like I've never played a
tournament like this in college it was a
different kind of experience because I
was you know doing a couple hours of
homework too every night
um and also you know I definitely my
games were very
um some of them are quite not too pretty
look at but it was definitely like a
really good mental challenge especially
since
um the way I lost my game against Irina
around 12 and I came back from it like
I'm really proud that you know I didn't
just kind of give up the tournament
because it was really hard for me to
accept that loss because it was just how
can you lose in that way so I think I
definitely took really valuable lessons
from both of these events
also I noticed that today Jennifer came
to the tournament with the smile you
were really kind of in a good mood did
you feel that you're going to win or not
at all
how is
I guess I would say I was nonchalant
because I did not feel ready going into
this
um I felt like I needed to prep more and
then I realized like it's so fast it's
truly so fast like you can't really know
what to expect especially like this
ending here like I don't think anyone
could have guessed this would happen
would have happened so I didn't know
that I was someone but I was like no
matter what's going to happen it'll be
okay like it was good effort
um because
like I said like this tournament I
learned so many things over this
tournament already yeah
yeah thanks a lot Jennifer Jennifer
congratulations great job great spirit
well done
and once more let's uh sum it up women's
results
Anastasia now we have final standings so
Jennifer you just won these
championships she became the US Women's
Champion 2022. absolutely
congratulations
right she showed us to such a great
spirit in this event and she fought
Until the End second place in the U.S
Champion women's chess championships I
can only imagine arena is just thinking
what just happened it's just believing
that she could be a whole piece up and
allow her opponent back into the game it
was painful and once more in the open
our big shout out congratulations to
Fabiano caruana on his second Victory
yes the U.S championships and then we
have Ray Robson on the second place and
Linea Dominguez and the Wonderland
shared the third place yep all the way
down there and I saw Christopher you and
there we have our champion sixty
thousand dollars now what what is he
going to do I mean
a different five years I saw him today
in the morning yes yes he was passing by
and for the Armageddon she chose black
she won it on time actually uh that's
four and B's down
he's a hero Christian do your best try
your best to try to sum up what you just
saw oh okay oh yes okay congratulations
we have to admit yes I fell across the
Finish Line with Barbara
yeah yeah nicely done right yeah we had
it all oh
[Laughter]
give me the money yesterday right no you
you you were right on with the open that
was very very good Chris Christian I I'm
still I'm I'm words fail I just can't
help
help what happened and by the way
reminder that later today we have the
closing ceremony and anybody who is in
San Luis now can still jump to this boat
and to come to the closest ceremony
which starts at 6 PM only 25 dollars and
you're here and you can see the players
so we start with cocktail party closing
ceremony and then we have after party
with DJ if you cannot do it please check
our St Louis chess club YouTube channel
and watch the stream right okay come on
you do your best sum up what we just saw
because I I'm speechless
an amazing couple of weeks here in St
Louis calling all the action and some
amazing games amazing players we've seen
Fabiano caruana win his second uh title
after the chess 9 LX that he just won a
couple of weeks before the start of this
event so he's continuing his uh nice
stride but in the ladies section I mean
this match between Arena crash the
eighth time now national champion and
Jennifer Yu who is definitely looking to
follow in her Rivals footsteps because I
mean she's dreaming to surpass one day
those uh those Eight titles just an
incredible match and it just goes to
show that you can never give up in this
tournament she was a piece down she was
losing in the position absolutely no
chances we were like here okay this is
over the game is over let's go home
right I realize I just won her ninth
title it did not happen Jennifer you
came back from the dead and just turned
it all around and that was a career
defining moment that we just experienced
right now history in the making and I
had a lot of fun calling all the action
with you guys thank you for all the
support here in the studio it's been a
lot of fun
[Laughter]
I mean it was such a pleasure to be here
in the studio and follow all the action
I of course we will need to I don't know
get rid of this stress and tension all
right let's quietly recover our uh
balance somehow it was amazing I hope
you all enjoyed it again thank you so
much for joining us on the stream uh
subscribe follow
let us know how we're doing and again I
just want to say thanks thank you so
much to the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center everything you guys do
Rex and Genie you're just terrific
Anastasia Christian fist bumps to you my
friend yes thank you pleasure it was
really really something special say for
me
I don't want to close the shore but I
think we have to do it it was amazing
good night goodbye good night good
afternoon and see you maybe next time
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited